Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since the
Time Lords are trying to come back into the
regular Universe I wanted to float the theory
that we’ll see other Time Lords in Series
8, Series 9 or some point in the future.
This opens the door for people that may not
necessarily make good Doctor’s, but would
make excellent Time Lords.
Just remember of all the voices from The Doctor’s
Wife.
I’ll also be doing a video for my top 10
choices for a new companion next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it and leave suggestions
in the comments.
One of the beauties of all this is that new
Time Lords can be quick cameos, opening the
door to some of our more favorite actors that
are too busy to play The Doctor himself.
Cue the fan fiction!
Number 10 - Andrew Scott.
He’s been the quintessential villain since
Sherlock Series 1 but his portrayal of Moriarty
has this playfulness that feels just like
a madman in a box.
There have even been some Sherlock actors
that guested during Matt Smith’s run like
Rupert Graves.
As much fun as it would be to see him become
Doctor Who’s greatest nemesis The Master,
I feel like that would too obvious of a choice.
So giving Scott the opportunity to channel
his crazy performance into a good character
would be a nice change of pace.
And he’d still have all of Time and Space
with which to cause mischief.
Number 9 - Tom Hardy as The Warrior.
The existence of the War Doctor is proof that
Time Lords can be Warriors.
So wouldn’t it be fun to see the very large
physically imposing Tom Hardy play a Time
Lord that was still in a warrior incarnation
of himself.
Just because you’re a warrior doesn’t
mean you have to be a villain.
The Doctor’s code, Never Cruel or Cowardly
is something unique to him.
Not all Time Lords have to have laid down
their swords after the Time War ended.
I’d really like to see Peter Capaldi meet
another Warrior Time Lord and try to get him
to chill.
Or he could just be a big fun buiser like
Christopher Eccleston’s Doctor.
Number 8 - Jude Law.
The Pretty Boy Time Lord.
I’m just joking with the pretty boy, but
for a lot of his career that’s what Jude
Law was known as.
I think he’d do an amazing job of playing
a post-gender swapped Time Lord.
During Doctor’s Wife Matt Smith even alluded
to the fact he had a relationship with another
Time Lord that went from female to male.
Jude Law could totally play that character
or one like him.
Father kind of implied in that episode that
all of the gallifreyan message cubes belonged
to Time Lords he had killed.
Number 7 - Ralph Fiennes as a new Rassilon.
Timothy Dalton was amazing as Rassilon during
Russel T. Davies run, but because the tone
of the show has changed so much since the
10th Doctor and will continue to get darker.
I think Lord Voldemort would bring the right
level of intensity to the ruler of the Time
Lords.
There have been a lot of theories about where
Rassilon was during the events of the 50th
Anniversary.
And confusion over whether or not he’s still
trapped in that Time Locked bubble from End
of Time.
But for the purposes of this video, let’s
assume he’s on Gallifrey with all the other
citizens right now.
Vote Yes For Lord Voldemort Rassilon!
Number 6 - Dame Helen Mirren as The Woman
in White.
So many theories about her being the Doctor’s
mother, but let’s assume that she’s not
so we can open the doors on making her a good
foil for River Song.
Also rumored to return.
Who would ever be able to out-River Song River
Song but The Queen of England.
She’s such an amazing actress she could
play any of the major characters on the show
like a Female Master, making her The new Woman
in White would just be a good pairing for
an episode or future anniversary special that
featured my Rassilon dream-pick Ralph Fiennes.
Not that you have to feature both characters
in the same story, it’s just that the last
time we saw them they were in close proximity.
Number 5 - Gwendoline Christie as Romana.
Pre-50th Anniversary her status was alive
slash unknown.
In some of the non-tv series material she
even took Rassilon’s job as President for
a brief period.
Regardless of the previous portrayals of the
character.
As Brienne on Game of Thrones Gwendoline is
one of the most positive and powerful women
in Science Fiction and Fantasy, super powers
notwithstanding.
The Woman in White is another powerful female
Time Lord, but I always viewed that character
being played by an older actress.
Romana on the other hand seems like it would
be a better choice for someone younger.
Gwendolyne would be about 3 inches taller
than Capaldi, so it would make for some great
visual gags too.
As in you may be a mentor to me, but I am
probably going to be the one to pull your
ass out the Time Fire.
Number 4 - Hugh Laurie as The Meddling Monk.
Think Blackadder, Jeeves and Wooster Hugh
Laurie, not House Hugh Laurie.
We spent so much time watching him playing
a character that resembled the War Doctor.
It would be so much fun to watch Laurie go
back to his comedy roots and play a Loki-type
Time Lord.
He’s not evil, he just likes to make a mess
of things.
Who better to clean them up than the stern
12th Doctor.
Just picture Capaldi giving Laurie the stare.
Number 3 - Ben Whishaw as The Scholar.
I don’t really see him playing the same
type of Time Lord as a hulking Tom Hardy,
but Ben Whishaw was one of my top picks for
the 12th Doctor before Peter Capaldi was announced.
Imagine an amalgam of his characters from
James Bond and The Hollow Crown.
I’d really like to see him as a bookish
Time Lord who Capaldi would go to for assistance
with an unsolvable riddle.
Picture his TARDIS looking like a more grand
version of the one we saw in Series 7.
Number 2 - Tom Hiddleston.
Starting to break into the realm of fan fiction
but this is a wish list.
He even co-starred with Whishaw in The Hollow
Crown.
He’s been the consummate bad guy since Thor
but I think he has the perfect level of ambiguity
that would be perfect for a Time Lord.
The Doctor always said that the Time War twisted
his people, Imagine the scene in Avengers
where Loki steps out of the portal for the
first time looking haunted and derranged.
But not totally evil.
Imagine a Time Lord burdened with glorious
purpose.
Mewling Quims for the win.
and my number 1 pick for a new Time Lord.
Chiwetel Ejiofor.
The rumored almost-12th Doctor.
Chiwetel was supposedly the anglo-african
actor offered the role of The Doctor but then
turned it down.
This is all based on conjecture from a statement
Neil Gaiman made.
But it’s since passed into fan fic legend.
If he was good enough to play the Doctor and
he’s probably going to win a Best Actor
Oscar, just think of what he would bring to
a Time Lord character.
So there’s a lot of amazing actors like
Idris Elba, Eddie Redmayne, Aiden Turner and
Benedict Cumberbatch.
But we have to set aside a few for potential
choices for a new “Master”.
If there’s anything I really want to see
from Series 8 and Capaldi’s run it’s a
new major Time Lord character.
Not one that we see all the time.
Just someone really important like Rassilon
or even River Song.
Based on a lot of comments from the production
staff everyone thinks we’ll be seeing a
lot of Classic Who bits returning but I also
really hope Moffat introduces something big
and new into the Canon.
Now it’s your turn, let me know which actors
you’d love to see play a Time Lord in Series
8 or 9.
Think young actors and old.
They can even play pre-existing characters.
Unless we get some big surprise news from
the set, my next Doctor Who video will be
10 picks for a new companion either in addition
to or in replacement of Jenna Louise Coleman.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
We don’t know if she’s going to stay on
for series 9 yet.
Right now click here to learn more about Series
8 and click here for my Sherlock Series 4
Predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you tomorrow.
High Fives!